[تصفيق]
المدن تختفي عن بكره ابيها احياء باكملها
تنزل الى باطن الارض في ثوان معدوده
والارض تبتلع ما فوقها الصراخ ياتي من كل
مكان والاراضي اصبحت قاعا مسطحه كانها
البحار والمحيطات الناس ينتقلون من الدنيا
الى الاخره في لحظه واحده يا لا قوه
الخالق انه زلزال واحد حصد مئات الارواح
وعشرات المباني وبعض المدن وما خفي كان
اعظم يا الهي هل هو سخط الهي ام ابتلاء
واصيب به المغرب لكن هل ينتهي الامر عند
هذا الحد ام ان للزلزال رايا اخر ليظهر
العالم الهولندي نذير الشؤم في العالم
ويجيب رمز زلزال المملكه المغربيه نتحدث
وللقصه بقيه كارثه مغربيه في ليله الجمعه
والساعه تقترب من اليوم انها الحاديه عشره
يا ساده فجاه ودون سابق انذار اهتزت الارض
في المغرب وهو ما بعث الفزع في المنطقه
بعد الاثار المدمره التي خلفها في مدن
مراكش واكادير عدد من المناطق المغربيه
تاركا مئات القتلى والمصابين وحتى لحظه
كتابه هذا الفيديو فهناك 190 وفاه في
اقليم
الحوزاه في اقليم تارودانت وتس
في اقليم شيشاوه وثلاثون وفاه في اقليم
ورزازات و13 وفاه في مراكش و11 وفاه في
اقليم ازيلال وخمس وفيات في اجادير نعم
وبحسب اخر الاحصائيات لوزاره الداخليه
المغربيه فنحن امام
822 قتيلا والقائمه تطول وهذا ما ظهر حتى
الان وما بقيت تحت الانقاض سيكشف عنه
لاحقا ومع كل تلك الوفيات بلغت الاصابات
[موسيقى]
غير قادر على الخروج يا الهي ما هذا الذي
يحدث نذير الشؤم السلطات المغربيه تعلن ان
معظم الوفيات كانت في مناطق الجبال التي
يصعب الوصول اليها اما المعهد الوطني في
المغرب فافاد بانه تم تسجيل زلزال بقوه
سبع درجات على مقياس ريختر باقليم الحوز
وسط البلاد مشيرا الى ان الهزات
الارتداديه عقب الزلزال الذي ضرب المغرب
يمكن ان تتواصل لبضعه ايام او بضعه اسابيع
قبل ان تختفي بما قال هيئه المسح
الجيولوجي الامريكيه انه اقوى زلزال يضرب
هذا الجزء من شمال افريقيا منذ اكثر من
قرن اصبح العالم يتشائم من ظهوره ونحن
نتحدث عن العالم الهولندي
فمع حدوث اي زلزال في اي مكان في العالم
فيظهر سموه على السطح تلقائيا وهو ما حدث
مع وقوع زلزال المغرب العنيف
[موسيقى]
وفي السادس من سبتمبر حدث تقارب اخر مع
عطارد والزهره متوقعا مجموعه من الهزات
القويه قريبا بين الخامس والسابع من
سبتمبر في المنطقه لكن الذي حدث ان زلزال
المغرب تاخر يوما واحدا عن توقعه فهل تصيب
توقعات هذا العالم الهولندي دائما ام انها
مجرد مصادفات هل علينا ان نعتقد ان كل ما
يقوله هذا العالم سيحدث مع انتشار اخبار
الزلزال في العالم شرعت الدول في تجهيز
المساعدات للمناطق المتضرره اللهم الطف
باخواننا في المغرب واجرهم في مصيبتهم
[موسيقى]